welcome back everybody monday morning 6
44.
hello monica jackson good morning monica
hey good morning guys hope you guys had
a great weekend i know the kids are
getting back to school so i want to get
right into this segment okay because
it's all about protecting your devices
mom dad all the teachers in school
i need you to listen up i got a local
expert here his name is adnan kawaja
and adnan is the owner of sky vista
consulting this guy is like
he has a big brain he knows how to help
you protect all your stuff okay
we'll just leave it at that adna thank
you so much for being here how you doing
i'm doing excellent today monica thank
you
i appreciate you being here for mondays
with monica adnan i'm going to go right
into it i think we have a couple full
screens i want to ask you these
questions
and i need you to answer them concisely
and not the big words that technical
people use okay
i promise i'll try to be as limited as
possible okay so the first one is when
it comes to protecting
uh our computers from uh and from
viruses you have some anti-virus
software you want to tell us about there
are three of them we have the first one
up on the screen
it's called malwarebytes talk about that
one for me
yeah so you know with with antivirus
softwares i mean uh male revive fights
is just one of the
recommendations that we have in terms of
protecting your machine and malware
you know bytes itself is really good to
actually uh
uh check on you know different malwares
that's also on your on your device
in real life you know on runtime
essentially okay so
so that's that's one of the
recommendations that we have in terms of
uh you know
using malware ongoing and then uh
you know if if something comes up on
screen
the software pretty much tells you right
okay and it is affordable right adnan
it's absolutely affordable i mean the
recommendations that are there
are you know affordable for parents uh
you know businesses alike
okay all right now the second one you
recommend is called bit defender talk
about that one real quick for me
yeah so a big defender you know if you
don't mind i can i could probably talk
about kaspersky
as well oh sure go ahead yeah so you
know just kind of
putting it all together i mean kaspersky
and bitdefender they're all pretty much
wire scanners
uh you know windows itself has a virus
scanner but you know just
adding extra layers of defense in order
to make sure that you're always
protected is
is always a good thing to have so you
know bitdefender is one of the
the top recommended outside of the the
mainstream ones that you've heard like
norton or
mcafee and uh you know it's it's a
it's a great one to have because as kids
or businesses go through different
websites
it act prompts you in case the website's
not secured okay
and if it is it you know you could add
an exception okay
now let's talk about security measures
slash programs here
the first one is vpn now i'm not as
smart as you are with this stuff but
i've heard about vpn
and we have it on our devices talk about
that one for me
yeah so vpn essentially is called a
virtual private network and what that
does is you know it kind of
you know you you probably have heard on
different browsers that they recommend
going incognito
and vpn is almost kind of going into
that realm of being incognito so hackers
or controllers are trying to you know
get into your
ip addresses uh it sort of covers it so
you know
essentially it's almost falsing your uh
your
location so to speak so you don't have
to worry about
like somebody tapping into your machine
right away so it's it's a good way of
you know protecting you know your
machine in general
okay i got one minute left adnan the
number two is lastpass
and then number three you say
maintenance of your machine devices talk
about those two for me last pass first
yeah so so everybody talks about
password protection so lastpass is one
of them
and a good mechanism for you to keep you
know track of your passwords without
having to save on your browser itself
so at google mobile that's one way and
uh you know the other question was
uh what was the other question
maintenance of your machine and your
devices
absolutely so i recommend you know do a
late night maintenance so anytime after
12 or 1 o'clock in the morning
you know run those wire scanners ongoing
so this way you're always
protected and you know anytime there's
always runtime protection too
okay got it so folks just a quick review
anti-virus software malwarebytes
bitdefender and kaspersky and when it
comes to security measures vpn
lastpass and make sure to maintain your
devices adding i think this was perfect
timing
everybody the kids are going back to
school parents gotta you know jump on it
and double down on
protecting all of that wear so to get in
touch with adam go to
skyvistaconsulting.com
i promise you the jackson family was hit
with malware that's why i really wanted
to talk about this
and it was not fun this guy helped us
out and he can help you as well
and thank you so much we appreciate you
absolutely
appreciate being on here all right take
care and don't forget to catch my moj
show facebook live weeknights
at 7 pm we'll have a repeat